Picture this: it’s an average Thursday night.
You’re just doing your thing — that thing being
playing your groovy blue red combo deck in a
game of commander with all your cool friends.
You’re out there, drawing the cards,
making the plays, living your best
life. The pivotal moment fast approaches.
A pesky Thalia hits the board—not to fear,
you’ve got a counter. Your Kiki-Jiki meets a
Dissipate—and though the ensuing counter war
is lost, you’ve got a back-up plan.
You throw down that Splinter Twin.
What follows is those dreaded words.
“In Response.” It’s a removal spell.
Suddenly, this game has become a lot
less cozy. What’s the backup plan,
champ? You keep cycling through your deck, finding
plenty of draw and mana, but nothing much of use.
Things are desperate. Where do you even go from
here? Well, you don’t. Go from here, I mean.
Combo holds an interesting position within the
landscape of Magic: the Gathering. Is it a type of
deck? A type of wincon? A flavor of playstyle?
Yes, it is indeed these things, and many
more probably. The basic gist of what combo is is
exactly what it sounds like—a combination of cards
that together do something much stronger, but that
can take a lot of forms. The spooky scary version
is a two or three card combo that wins on the
spot, such as Splinter Twin Pestermite, but there
also exist infinite life and infinite mana combos
that need additional cards to win, as well as less
game-ending combos that only kill situationally,
or even just create a lot of value. Though combo
is wide-ranging and has undoubtedly been a part of
the game for basically its whole existence, many
players have a negative association with it, and
I think it’s useful to go over why that might be.
To start with, it’s pretty common for combo decks
to feel un-interactive, and like they win out of
nowhere. You can be doing your own game plan and
watching with dread as your opponent spends very
little resources on board state and interaction,
instead relentlessly digging their way toward a
one turn win until either they find it or you
reduce their life total to zero. This kind of
magic isn’t particularly fun for anybody—it’s
just another kind of solitaire. The other thing
I’ve seen complaints about is the fact that, in
a way, a lot of combo decks break the rules of
the game as understood by most players. Games
that involve conventional aggro, midrange,
and control decks feature a common language—board
presence is a thing to be fought over, and cards
and life total exist as resources to be taken
into consideration and leveraged. By contrast,
combo decks throw this playbook in the toilet—they
operate using additional, more subtle resources,
and they can win even when they are behind
in board state, life total, and hand size.
Now, there are a lot of things to be said about
these points, but I’ll keep it to this for now—the
volatility and un-interactiveness of combo decks
can indeed be negatives, and I’ll be talking about
how to minimize them. However, breaking the
conventional rules of the game can be a good
thing, particularly in a format like EDH. The
fact that commander is a format with 40 health
per player and three opponents rather than one
encourages some styles of play which are too
risky in 20 health 1v1 formats. These empowered
styles tend to be slower and greedier than a lot
of what you find in other formats. In mid-power
EDH it’s very common to see decks that pile on
heaps upon heaps of creature-based value, and then
you get decks like my Glissa list, calling card
“Midrange Crusher 5000”, that make it their whole
goal to demolish these sort of decks by piling on
an even larger amount of greed. And though I
enjoy playing Midrange Crusher 5000, I know
that this environment isn’t always a very dynamic
one. A game where everyone always has big piles
of value-generating permanents and where turns
involve five minutes of abilities and triggers
with little movement or strategy or actual action
isn’t one I enjoy finding myself in. The fact
that there are decks that can cut through slow,
greedy, board-centered decks is a good thing.
Now that I’ve laid out why I think combos
and combo decks occupy a useful niche,
we can ask the question of the video:
where do they usually go wrong in EDH?
I think a lot of it comes down to the
structure of decks. The example I gave
in the intro is a deck that’s basically an EDH
adaptation of 2015-era modern Splinter twin,
a pure combo deck. And the operative word for
why that doesn’t work so well is *pure*. So okay,
there’s this weird paradoxical thing—as you
get to higher and higher powers in commander,
combo becomes more and more ubiquitous for the
simple fact that everybody’s got 120 health to
chisel through, right, and it takes a lot of time
to fair-magic your way through that level of meat.
But what this also means is that stax cards to
slow down and break combos also become ubiquitous,
much more ubiquitous than they are in a
20 health 1v1 format. The result is that
pure combo actually works better in conventional
formats, and it is indeed very common for combo
decks in these formats to have no other wincons.
By contrast, for a high power commander player,
who must always contend with the possibility
of encountering a quagmire of stax effects
and counterspells, it’s a good idea to
run alternate wincons just to be safe.
As a high level example, we can consider
Dargo-Thrasios, a partner commander pair
that is sometimes played in competitive EDH.
Thrasios is a beast of a card—it’s a generally
decent value engine, and more importantly,
it’s an outlet for infinite-mana combos that’s
in the command zone—you combo off to get your
infinite mana, and then you play Thrasios and
draw through your deck to find the kill. Good
stuff, Thrasios is real good. Dargo is there
to add a bunch of utility—he can be used with
Life’s Legacy or Greater Good to generate cards,
and he can also be sac-ed to Neoform or Pod to
grab Tidespout for one of the deck’s combos. He
also, more pertinently to the point here, is a
beefy boy who can three tap your opponents, and
that can be a useful thing to have in your pocket
if your combo plan gets shut down somewhere along
the road. The multiple different combo wincons
along with a backup beatdown wincon make the
deck exceedingly flexible and adaptable, and help
it to weather a lot of challenging situations.
However, I hear a clamoring. But Alex, I hear some
of you say. I’m not a cEDH player. I’m not going
to be facing a wall of stax high enough to be an
eighth wonder of the world. And you know what,
that’s fair. So for now let’s stop considering
what’s good, and switch to considering what’s fun
and what works well within a somewhat lower-power
group. For starters, I’m gonna have to crush your
dreams a little. Combos are powerful and
can be quite fun, but it’s important that
the combos be well-situated within a deck. This
means that if the combo is central to the deck,
the deck should be able to pull it off reasonably
consistently with the assumption of at least
light resistance from your opponents. If
the combo is less central to the deck,
it should blend in naturalistically with the
deck, requiring mostly cards and types of
setup that the deck achieves through its normal
gameplan and not feeling wildly out of sync
with the normal gameplan. If you put a two card
infinite combo in your low-power midrange deck,
your deck is gonna be a low-power midrange deck
90% of the time and an unprotected infinite
combo deck 10% of the time. That’s gonna
give your playgroup some serious whiplash,
and it’s decidedly not an example of fun
and dynamic gameplay. See part two of my
budget cards video if you wanna hear me waffle
about this topic for another five minutes or so.
For an example of an elegant execution of a
lower-power combo deck, I’m gonna use a deck
from my friend Mr. Hans, because he’s much
more of a Johnny than I’ll ever be. He built
a Vadrok deck—it’s a toolbox mutate deck that
tries to generate value through its commander
and a suite of other value engines throughout
the deck. An equipment subtheme with several
tutors also exists within the deck, giving it
access to several reconfigure cards which offer
various forms of utility, as well as the central
pillar of the deck—Sunforger. With Sunforger,
the deck has access to yet a further
suite of options—assorted interaction,
draw spells, burst damage, and also a couple of
distinctly spicier cards. Glorious End can put
an immediate stop to a problematic combat phase
or effectively counter a concerning spell, and
Chance for Glory is an extra turn spell that also
doubles as a protection spell. For both cards,
Angel’s Grace can be played on that following
turn in order to prevent the lose-the-game clause.
Now, this is a decidedly useful tool on its own,
but it is also within the interaction between
these cards and the mutate mechanic that the combo
exists. Vadrok can repeat low-cost noncreature
spells from the graveyard when creatures mutate
onto it, and since the mutate stack counts as a
single creature, a bounce spell returns the entire
stack to hand. So… the combo goes something like
this. Get an extra turn via Chance for Glory and
prevent loss on that turn via Angel’s Grace. Then,
repeat this on each subsequent extra turn
by mutating three creatures onto Vadrok—one
for Chance, one for Grace, and one for a
bounce spell. If you have the correct setup,
this means infinite turns and infinite
combat steps swinging with Vadrok.
Now, the first thing you should note is that,
as combos go, this one is very convoluted
and difficult to achieve. In addition to
the three cards required for the combo,
there is also the requirement of having
14 mana and three mutate creatures, as
well as the commander. However, this is actually
okay, for a couple different reasons. For one,
Vadrok isn’t a pure combo deck—maintaining a
solid mutate stack with the commander leads
to having a decent beater that deals commander
damage and generates a lot of value. The deck
isn’t playing at high power levels, and it can
and does win games simply by hitting people,
drawing cards, and holding up enough
protection to prevent the stack from
dying. A common strategy for the deck is
to build the stack on top of a manland,
which allows it to dodge sorcery speed removal
in general and board wipes in particular, and the
pivotal Sunforger boosts Vadrok’s power to 7—the
exact amount you need to kill a player in three
hits. It’s a very real win plan, with a solid
shell for generating value and controlling things.
The other reason the difficulty of setting
up the combo is okay is that all three of
the combo pieces have their own utility, and more
importantly, the requirement of having a lot of
mutate creatures and mana is achieved by the deck
just generally doing what it wants to be doing.
Generating a lot of value leads to drawing into
mutate creatures and mana rocks, and successfully
protecting its ever-important Sunforger allows the
deck to grab its combo pieces. Everything needed
to set up the combo is a solid goal in its own
right, so simply playing the deck in ways that
are generally effective also naturalistically
leads into having the combo. Sometimes the combo
will get stopped, but if it does, guess what?
The deck has been doing a good job of pursuing
its general goals, so you’re still gonna have
a decent shot of winning via commander damage.
This idea of the combo fitting naturally into the
deck is the biggest thing I want to convey here.
A combo you run shouldn’t feel abrupt or out of
place—it shouldn’t feel like the deck either does
nothing or everything depending if it draws
a certain 3 or 4 cards. If you’ve got a deck
where a combo is the centerpiece, it should have
tutors or big piles of draw in order to get there,
with control cards used as a sort of extending
element to buy the deck time. If you have a
deck where it’s going to take a long time to put
together the combo, you should fill up space in
the deck with a game plan that works concurrently
with setting up the combo. That can be ramping in
a deck where the combo is mana-intensive, running
lots of draw in a deck where the combo involves
looping with a number of different cards, or
running lots of tutors in a deck where getting
discrete pieces together is a challenge. And then,
once you’ve constructed a framework for piling on
particular resources, you can devise how to fit in
an alternative winplan that also takes advantage
of these resources. Don’t trust your combo to
win you the game—because guess what? Removal,
counterspells, and stax exist, and optimizing
your combo deck is going to put you at power
levels where increasing quantities of these
roadblocks exist. The higher power you get,
the more useful it becomes to just
have a good, old-fashioned beefy lad.
As a final point, I want to discuss the
opposite of a combo deck with an alternative
beatdown wincon—that being a beatdown deck
with an alternative combo wincon. Now,
this is a little more unusual, but hear me out
here. Sometimes a beatdown deck is able to get
ahead on resources, but then it gets locked out
of swinging for on-board damage for some reason
or other. For example, a couple years back
I built a $25 Grismold, the Dreadsower deck,
a fast midrange deck. Plan A of the deck is
the pseudo-Voltron beatdown plan where the
deck creates a bunch of tokens on board and then
deletes said tokens in order to swing for lethal
amounts of commander damage. You might note,
however, that the deck is not running blue,
and a $25 budget is too small to afford nice
shoes for my Grismold, and as you might expect,
there are games where Grismold kinda just
gets bullied out of existence by removal.
So, what else can you do with a lot of tokens
dying? Run some Blood Artist effects, of course.
The win plan of generate tokens, play Syr Konrad,
and then kill the tokens isn’t as effective at
killing players as a pure voltron Grismold
plan, but relying on the Grizzy plan alone
is a bad idea, and having a backup means that
the deck can win even if it just gets a couple
medium-sized Grismold swings rather than living
the dream and one-tapping three players back to
back. The important point here is that both of
these wincons use the same basic resource—tokens,
so the deck doesn’t really need to *do* anything
different to have both of these wincons. And this
is the crux of things, really. At lower powers,
alternate wincons should ideally be using the
same resources as the main wincon for the
sake of deck cohesion. And when in doubt,
just engineer your deck so that it has
a meaty lad it can use, just in case.